yes I do appear in episode 10 of season
3 yes I will be leaving everything on a
cliffhanger at the end of episode 10 yes
we live it with cliffhanger in Kyoto and
so we're yeah love it it should be she
put it pretty pretty cool I think now
we've seen a lot of Theon of course
already in season 3 he's not having a
very happy time it's a bit of pickle
listening he's seen a bit of a bit of a
bit of a fix isn't he he's going self in
their trouble if only you'd listened to
me really yeah you did say that you can
trust his men didn't you I did say that
he just needed to do what he was told
and typical man actually maybe that's
not fair to say but poor OCR knees and
he's misguided isn't evil so we've seen
when you see him again will you be
saying told you so I would definitely be
saying I told you so when I see him
again but yes
still love him he's my brother I just
say it's very difficult situation she's
been in this season but if you're I had
been in that same situation could have
quite different people aren't they how
do you think she would have coped oh
they are very different people I think I
think she'd have cooked really well
I bet she would perhaps have used a
little more wit and nowis I think to get
around things but he just fell into
every chap that was going didn't he poor
thing
I think she might be a little bit more
wily a bit more wise to it perhaps she
sets her own trap so she might be a you
know wise to her the trap setters
perhaps the messer and the Messi exactly
exactly yeah yeah so do you think she's
a cunning Fox then we'll be seeing more
of that as the season and next season
and future seasons go on I think I think
she's a cunning yes but I think she also
has a strong sense of family and what
she feels is right for her and so yeah I
think we'll see a lot more of that side
of her coming out
of course we love Yarra we'd like to see
it see her survive for a long time in
Game of Thrones but what are the
qualities do you think that you need to
survive lots of Mouse and intelligence
and balls and yeah determination I
supposed to feeling like you're a might
be ticking all the boxes so far yeah I
think she does yeah she's certainly
determined and stubborn and but but also
this sense of family she has you know
that she has I think she's she wants she
over writes her father I think was some
of the the cold-heartedness that he has
I think she's a little warmer in terms
of when it comes to Theon do you think
they'll be quiet maybe a big
reconciliation scene or a scene where
they you know have get back together and
Theon and Yara and maybe discuss things
that have gone on previously everyone
ice cup of tea okay Battenberg maybe
11:00 hey Kiara Theo sit down to some
lemon drizzle I would love it if we
could but who knows with was happening
to Theon presently that it that it can
can perhaps happen but not not in the
know in the near future they had a
chance before it's bit of a sparring
match between him a verbal one hasn't it
been a little bit of a verbal sparring
match and my father's very upset with
what I called C on but yeah this in a
battle of wits and determination isn't
it certainly when you had to prepare
yourself for that scene the dumbest
moments how did you work up through it
is it bad to say I didn't have to work
saying that word too much I tell you
what though I did have to work up that
scene a little bit because it was the
first scene we shot at also we shot out
of sequence completely so that season
eight so episode eight spring pardon and
which is where I really appear in
real-time last in that series we shot
first it was my first day I was
terrified and yeah I I was very nervous
on set that morning
and I think sometimes never very good
for your honor they really keep you
alive and and of course it was Alan
Taylor directing that day and just
brilliant and Alf and I'd gotten very
well so it was it was as easy as it it
could have been in order for me to do my
job and hopefully it came off all right
now I'm wintering obviously you're kind
of team Greyjoy the house Greyjoy
absolutely yeah but if you had to bet
money on who would come out on top on
Game of Thrones would you put it on how
stark Lannister or Targaryen or do you
think the Greyjoy is like my you know
turn around Lord I've got funny I've got
a feeling about the Lannisters I think
they seem to be just that little bit
what's the word it's that one step
further prepared to take the to take a
bullet I suppose you know the Starks
perhaps they're a little warmer and I
think the the Lannisters could really
they've got that edge that nasty edge
heavenly when with Tyrion kind of
leading the way I think I think they've
got something there but who knows of
course one of the things we love about
Game of Thrones - all those oh my god
WTF moment yeah what have been the most
striking ones for you so far oh
definitely when poor old brand got
pushed out the window for me was just
like what what what and yeah and to see
Jaime and Cersei getting on and then
bran and it's just so beautiful set up
and and then so tragic and you're like
yeah that was one moment particularly
worse and also I was even though I sort
of knew we was gonna happen I was very
heartened when when we found the
children and with them the maester when
we found bran and Rickon safe that
wasn't more of a Muslim not so much a
WTF moment is that thank goodness even
though I knew you I said I just want to
see them yeah a few moment exactly yeah
yeah you had a bit of an oh my god
moment in your own audition or at least
it was a bit of an oh my god
tell me about the audition that you did
for the game of Thrones and the audition
that the first meeting that I had I had
to do my introduction to Theon scene so
I had to sort of sit on a chair
pretending it was a horse and get to
work on an imaginary chap behind me if
you will and that was interesting but
yeah the casting director is phenomenal
and he was he made me feel very at ease
comfortable and so I just went for it if
you can go for it with a chair I did my
best and I got records what happened in
that room stays in that room that tape
is somewhere though goodness knows where
now there's a lot of feisty females on
the show of course and we've got a new
one this season to it with Diana Rigg
character home way we've been enjoying
seeing her on the show loved seeing her
I mean what an established legend
already and then just to be yeah she's
fantastic
what a brilliant casting and she's yeah
another strong female good to see she's
had some hilarious moments as well she
says what she thinks yes she go to Yura
says also what she thinks so
I think this characters might go on once
together I'd like to meet her I think
you're a nerd get on but yeah it's
certainly another strong female who says
speaks her mind and also there's a
lovely amount of human errors you've
mentioned so it's a great balance have
you asked you last time you spoke how if
you had to go out the show and obviously
we don't want you to go out the show how
you'd like to do it and he said by acts
or in a fight with a man now I'm
wondering I'm wondering if you could
have anybody at the other end of your ax
you know if you could give anyone the
chop who would it be in the show who
would you like to see I think a nasty
character I'd like to get rid of them as
you're of course Littlefinger
yeah I think I'd think I'd give him a
slice definitely because he's a coward
isn't he I think amongst other things
there's a quite a cowardly part of him
and I would I would like to see his face
as I wielded my axe I think you've said
this season as well he's a most
dangerous man in Westeros he isn't he's
getting going up that ladder pretty
quickly
yeah real sneaky slimy fashion he is
definitely working his way up do you
think your had make mincemeat of him
yeah I do
she manipulates some sort of situation
where he felt safe and then chop his
head off if you had a choice obviously
it treads on your characters hawk but if
you could work with anybody who would it
be
I would love to work with Charles dance
and I love it I would love to have some
scenes with Peter Dinklage as well that
would be fantastic and I'd like to meet
some women
I haven't met any other women I mean I I
love men that sounds wrong
I love them my character hangs out with
men that's a great perk but it would be
nice to meet up with like say maybe
Diana Rigg or or Amelia something get
some get the girls together we do you
like your own dragons I would love my
own dragons who wouldn't yeah yeah maybe
where maybe I could just show up and
rocking a dragon on my shoulder one day
likes oh definitely not like the books
guys but uh check out my dragon say it
like that as well yeah I'm stuck out
guys and what I really told like Aziz
then I got a dragon yeah that would be
worrying and funny for a moment and then
what's she doing anyway and what's it
meant for you to be part of Game of
Thrones demo
I know it's welcome what it's meant for
me I fear everywhere the Oscars gonna
cement from you guys as I'm gonna cry
and know it's been wonderful I suppose
it in terms of you know for having that
on my CV and getting other work and
meeting fantastic people just working at
such a level where you just see the
production values are so high and the
other acts are so skilled and yeah it's
just I suppose it unless what it's meant
for me but more that I just feel very
lucky and that happened to be in the
right place at the right time to get
cast in this and yeah - just remember
how lucky I am because it's a coveted
show and I and I love it yeah and what
would you like to say to the fans of the
show and fans of you are here watching
out there watching what you're watching
a video here now well I said does anyone
know it's like because I've been signing
saying I've been like what I want to
write is always pay the iron price but
I'm like am i encouraging fevery so yeah
but why not always pay the iron price
guys and have fun
you